now as we know parts of the uk have been
hit by water shortages and grass fires
ahead of a met office amber alert for
extreme heat coming into force on
thursday a number of water suppliers
have introduced hose pipe bands thames
water is the latest supplier to signal
it may well bring one in in the coming
weeks well joining me now is stuart
colville director of policy for water uk
now this represents water companies
across the uk you're a body that's
funded by all the water companies um
how do you think they are doing at the
moment why is it that we are seeing some
areas where
there is obviously a problem with the
heat like thames water and like the
southeast introducing host pipe bands
but we're not for example seeing it in
other areas like anglia where they also
have very dry conditions
well companies are introducing temporary
use bands or hosepipe bands where that
becomes necessary and they take those
decisions based on a number of
indicators and so for example levels of
groundwater river flow
temperatures and so on and it's clear
that although the heat wave and other
weather conditions have been very
extreme recently the impacts have been
felt differently in different parts of
the country
and it's tended to be in the in the
south and centre of england where we've
seen some of the impacts felt worse
particularly on things like rivers some
of which have broken records recently
for their for their low flow and
companies are doing a huge amount in
response to that temporary use bands or
host pipe bands are just one of the ways
that we are responding there are lots of
other things as well we are changing the
way that we abstract water choosing
sources that are less under pressure
moving it around our regions differently
to help other users including
agriculture which has been hard hit and
we're also taking action to help the
environment so for example we are
sending pulses of cold water out of
reservoirs to rehydrate and cool rivers
where fish stocks have been under threat
so there's an enormous amount going on
but in some in some areas it has been
necessary to introduce these additional
restrictions to safeguard water supplies
and protect the environment
is it a coincidence that those who are
particularly bad at leaks are the ones
that appear to be putting in the host
pipe bands we know that thames water has
had a significant problem over the years
hasn't it
well leakage overall has come down over
a third since the 1990s and in fact of
what the economic regulator for the
water sector just last week i think put
out um confirmation that we've hit the
lowest ever level of re of of leakage on
record we've never had
so not hitting the targets that often
want the water companies to hit though
are they it's pushing for 16 and we saw
some like northumbria water hitting one
percent
we we are on track overall as a sector
to achieve a 16 reduction in leakage
between 2020 and 2025 which means that
our international performance on leakage
is actually very good if you compare us
with um comparison nations like italy or
indeed ireland all water companies
reduce leaks last year
though you are right that although the
majority hit their targets some while
reducing leaks didn't meet their targets
because those targets are really
stretching
should there be sanctions for water
companies that don't meet these leakage
targets
yeah so any company that doesn't meet
its targets uh is subject to some quite
high financial penalties and so there's
a very strong incentive to uh to every
company to to achieve them which is why
we've seen the progress that we have as
i say lowest ever levels of leakage on
record but i think the important thing
to remember is that leakage is not the
only thing that's important here we do
also need new sources of supply and
we've brought forward 18 new major
cross-country schemes uh which
regulators are scrutinizing now new
reservoirs new connections and that's
going to be part of the uh solution as
well as well as water efficiency where
actually we're asking government to make
some policy changes things like a water
efficiency label on appliances to help
customers understand
whether or not they're buying a leaky
dishwasher or a wasteful washing machine
all of that is part of how we will meet
the challenge of climate change over the
coming decades
high financial penalties you say for
leakages but not for the bosses of the
water companies we're seeing eye
watering bonuses being handed out to to
them
millions and millions of pounds do you
really think they're worth it
well i think the water industry is
investing over 10 billion pounds every
single year uh in some of the largest
infrastructure programs in europe i
think millions more if it didn't give
its bosses massive bonuses well i think
it's right that companies try and
attract the best possible talent
competing in a global market for for
some of these company leaders in order
to manage these massive infrastructure
programs after all it's actually quite
important that we have really good
company leaders given the importance of
the water sector for the environment and
for customers every day are they that
good if we are seeing hose pipe bans
leakages
massive problems across the country it
doesn't strike most of us if most of us
were doing that as our jobs it wouldn't
be seen as being especially good or at
the top of our field
if you if you look at the data from the
independent regulator off what then
you've seen massive improvements to um
almost every possible outcome for
customers whether that's customer
satisfaction whether that's leaks leaks
as i mentioned lowest ever on record
whether that's um supply interruptions
you've seen enormous progress over
recent decades and and that's what
companies have been getting on and
delivering
i mean these are targets that are you
know some some would question whether
they are targets that really are being
met and whether
really customers themselves
are really seeing a difference or
feeling a difference
uh so all the data is there on on the
off wall website and and people can go
and have a look equally i completely
understand that if you're someone who's
seeing maybe a leak spring up in the
street then of course
i understand that that is going to be
frustrating at a time when the water
industry is asking everyone to do their
bit as well
but i would say that we've made swift
progress we've got very aggressive
targets every year for the rest of this
decade to continue bringing leakage down
building on that lowest ever level of
recorded leakage
and on other customer outcomes as well
we were determined to keep on making
progress thames water today handing out
bottled water in the stoken church area
because they can't sort out the supply
there i mean again it just doesn't sound
like companies that have been very well
run
i'm not familiar with the the specific
example you you cite
where it does uh become necessary to
hand out uh bottled water in specific
limited circumstances then
actually we're well practiced at making
sure that customers
are supported during those difficult
times now fortunately the uk is in a is
in a much better position than some of
europe i think we saw an earlier report
where uh some of our peers in in other
nations maybe
don't don't enjoy some of that but but
on every outcome that uh that the data
is tracking we're showing good outcomes
for customers and the environment but
the fact of the matter is you pay your
water bill you expect water to come out
of your tap and you've got companies
that aren't managing to get water out of
taps to people you've got companies that
are saying please don't put water on
your gardens your companies that have
got leaks we saw this ludicrous leak in
east london last week where there was
four four feet of water just earlier
this week
and yet you seem to be saying that this
is an industry which is just doing
brilliantly everybody's ever so happy
and the guys that are running it are
worth these vast sums so there are huge
challenges of course and population
growth climate change the need to
further reduce abstraction to protect
the environment these are all challenges
that we're having to respond to um i
think i would i'd say that you know
leakage has come down by over a third
since the 1990s but there's clearly more
to do and that and that's something that
uh that we're working really hard on in
fact there are hundreds of people out as
we speak now uh finding and repairing
leaks we're using uh more advanced
techniques than ever before using
artificial intelligence drones
satellites we're using smart networks to
try and track these things and stop
leaks where they occur unfortunately
there will be uh there will be
occasional examples of leaks occurring
and in fact when soil becomes hard and
dry and is subject to very hot
conditions it does tend to crack and
move and put additional pressure on
pipes and you will sometimes see them
springing up for that reason which is
exactly why we have hundreds of people
out right now
to make sure that we're on those as fast
as we possibly can
okay stuart corville director of policy
water uk thank you very much for coming
on today